are you like making it a point to try to
stay away from jacksonville because i i
just don't know what what good can come
from you going home the cops ain't
[ __ ] with you there
you got your family your friends i'm
sure the people who matter closest to
you are probably with you where you're
at now
like is there a reason to go back home
besides maybe getting a bag or
you know i i don't know i just beat out
like truthfully for my brothers
sometimes i just be hanging out with my
brothers and [ __ ] yeah about it my
family really don't stay there my main
family i would say you took your family
out of there right yeah so i just really
beat up for my brothers trying to get
[ __ ] in line so we called just
you know i said movies want to get [ __ ]
together and [ __ ] is there a certain
point
where you hit a certain level of starter
more success where you
kind of say to yourself well listen to
the homies like hey y'all know
it's love but i can't be in the same
places y'all be at anymore because it's
just
you know counter counter
intuitive to what i'm trying to do
or is that something you're always going
to go back to no
not really because i still have been in
the same places i just
i know certain places i can't be in
jasper though like i ain't gonna go
downtown like by the police where the
police like that's done i just been in
my certain like areas why not downtown
because that's where the police like
really be real hot hot like oh so the
cops out there like it's like they all
they record they know they're hot
everywhere but downtown is like mainly
where they be stationed
it is how you move